hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine right here in
the heart of westminster
tonight's a shock resignation the prime
minister's own ethics adviser lord geit
has stepped down saying it was the right
thing to do it's apparently taken number
10 completely by surprise although just
yesterday lord guyt appeared in front of
a parliamentary committee admitting his
frustrations over how partygate was
handled what next for the prime minister
we'll bring you takes from all sides
over the next 60 minutes
of course you know resignation is is one
of the rather blunt but
few
tools available to an independent
advisor
well he of course has now decided to use
that blunt tool of resignation a downing
street source describing it as a
complete surprise to the prime minister
and of course the government was hoping
to move on from partygate in the house
of commons today the home secretary
priti patel was pushing the
controversial policy to send asylum
seekers to rwanda
the humane decent and moral response to
all of this is simply not to stand by
and let people down or to be sold into
slavery or to be smuggled but to stop
this
and it was an unusually colourful prime
minister's questions from the labour
leader kierstarma after his own mps
brief the papers that he was being a bit
too boring
as for his boasting about the economy
he thinks he can perform jedi mind
tricks on the country
these are the droids you're looking for
no rules were broken the economy is
booming
the problem is the force just isn't with
him anymore
[Applause]
he thinks he's obi-wan kenobi
the truth is he's jabber the heart
well the jury's out on the jokes uh but
certainly not a boring performance there
from uh kier stammer we're also of
course going to be taking the
temperature uh with the most important
people our panelists our viewers panel
we're going to be asking them about what
they make of the lord guide resignation
do they care here they all are thank you
so much for being here give us a little
wave looking forward to getting your
opinions later on in the programme we'll
also have some top guests on the show
including the home office minister tom
persglove we'll also be talking to
labour's shadow scottish secretary in
murray and the rotherham mp at celia
champion and much more besides too all
coming up on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good evening well westminster is
still reeling from the sudden
resignation of lord gait the prime
minister's ethics advisor who quit after
months of criticism over partygate and
questions over breaches of the
ministerial code it's not the only front
the government is battling on with
fights over brexit immigration and rail
strikes although you do get a sense the
prime minister may be more comfortable
fighting some of those battles than
others so let's crack straight on we're
going to start with the best bits of the
week so far the government insists that
its plans for new legislation to
override parts of the northern ireland
protocol will not break international
law we're very clear that we're acting
in line with the law now of course we
remain open to negotiations with the eu
i believe that
finally we are now seeing the kind of
action that is required
to begin the process of
removing the barriers for trade within
the united kingdom the british
government pulled back from negotiations
as far back as february and this year
and they haven't engaged in good faith
since that time and actually the whole
way through this whole brexit mess they
have reneged on political commitments
and i think that that makes them a very
uh bad faith partner we believe at this
stage is seven people who have been
earmarked for this flight to rwanda
there are a number of appeals going
through the high court at the moment if
those fail then they will be put on that
plane we are not going to be in any way
uh deterred or abashed by
some of the criticism that is being
directed upon this policy we are going
to get on and and deliver if they're not
on this flight they will be on the next
flight we want to break the model bring
you some breaking news in the past few
minutes sky news understands that the
plane which we'd uh talk so much about
at the start of the program due to
transport asylum seekers to rwanda will
not leave this evening it has saddened
me madam deputy speaker to see rwanda so
terribly misrepresented introduced
it is another example of how all too
often critics not only don't know what
they're speaking about but seek to
vilify another international country
it's not and never has been a serious
policy and she knew that when she
chartered the plane
she knew that among the people she was
planning to send to rwanda on this plane
were torture and trafficking victims i
mean these discussions uh were underway
when suddenly the the union decided it
would ballot its member telling them
incorrectly that it was to get them off
of pay freeze these are entirely
pointless counterproductive strikes they
should never have been called and the
party opposite should recognize that
breaking news in the last few minutes
the boris johnson's advisor on
ministerial interests has resigned
they go another pretty busy day in
westminster and our government guest
today of course i thought he was coming
on the program to talk about the
government's asylum seekers policy i
promise i will get to that of course um
but really this evening is dominated by
that resolution of uh lord gait we're
joined now uh by the home office
minister tom purd's glove to see if you
can shed any light on what happened and
do we know why lord guys has decided to
step down well sophie i've been i have
to say tour in the television studios
this evening talking about the latest
developments with regard to rwanda so i
haven't seen a huge amount on this but
of course lord guy has a distinguished
career in public service in a number of
roles i think we're surprised as a
government that he's taken the decision
that he hasn't of course it'll be for
him to set out in more detail the
reasons for why he's reached the
conclusion to resign that he has but i'm
sorry to see him go and um and thank him
for his service um you know you were
saying about how we were it's a surprise
for number 10 that that's what we've
been briefed as well and this
resignation but at the same time you
know he did go in front of this
committee uh didn't he saying that there
was um he was frustrated with some of
the responses to partygate he's
previously said that there was
legitimate questions over whether the
prime minister uh broke um the
ministerial code after receiving this
fine over party gate it feels like he
felt his position was untenable
defending the prime minister doesn't it
i think lord guy would need to speak for
himself obviously it has been an
eventful few weeks that we've seen i
think the prime minister has been very
clear consistently that in terms of what
happened with regard to gatherings in
number 10 he's apologized unreservedly
for that i think we now need to move
forward and get on with the job of
governing certainly in my own
constituency but also when i go around
the country and campaigning in the bio
elections for example i've heard a lot
of people saying that they just want
government to get on with the job of
governing they want the opposition to
talk about the issues that matter as
well i think that's where our focus
should now be but it's right that lord
guy sets those matters out in his own
terms in his own way in a way of his
choosing at the same time though it does
feel as though perhaps lord guyt had
reached the end of his tether defending
boris johnson they've had run-ins before
haven't they over the refurbishment of
the downing street flat when the prime
minister failed to disclose messages
between himself and a conservative peer
who paid for the
renovations lord geit said that
demonstrated insufficient respect for
his role the frustrations with boris
johnson had been well documented
i think that lord guy has been very
professional in his dealings in the work
that he's done and he's obviously
reached a conclusion that he wishes to
resign and that's what he's done and
it'll be for him to set out the reasons
why that's what he wishes to do um
i completely i understand that um you
can't put words in his mouth we haven't
really got a statement yet from uh lord
guy explaining those reasons and so i
appreciate the position you're in
at the same time though lord guide is
the second person to have resigned from
this job under boris johnson's
premiership i mean he's only been prime
minister for three years sir alex allen
quit in 2020 after mr johnson refused to
accept his finding that home secretary
pretty patel had bullied civil servants
it doesn't look good does it to lose not
one but two ethics advisors
again i'm not going to get drawn on this
i've not had much opportunity to
familiarize myself with we know we know
this happened we know you'll see people
have resigned from this frankly i
haven't got a sort of in-depth knowledge
of previous holders of the role and for
how long they've held the position for
um you know clearly there are term
lengths sometimes involved in public
appointments and people decide to serve
for a particular length of time there
may be personal reasons that he's
decided not to continue i don't know and
it would be wrong for me to speculate um
finally some some people might be
looking at us thinking
it shouldn't be lord guy resigning over
this it should be boris johnson he's
been fired from by the police for
breaking the rules uh 148 of his own mps
has said that they've got no confidence
in him
and he's now lost two ethics advisers
i don't think the prime minister should
resign he was given an overwhelming
mandate in that 2019 general election he
delivered brexit he's got us through the
pandemic the vaccination rollout was a
huge success and the government played a
part in delivering that we're now
emerging from kovid 19 we're dealing
with a situation in ukraine we've got
the cost of living challenges and i work
with him on the illegal migration issue
week in week out and i know how
determined he is to get to grips with
that i think that for the prime minister
there is still a lot more to give and he
is committed to getting on with a day
job delivering on the promises that we
made and i know that's what he's
determined to do even if i will
win a real wonder but even if you lose
both of the by-elections coming up in
wakefield and tivoton he's the man for
the job by-elections are unpredictable i
mean i obviously represent the corby
constituency we had a by-election in
2012 labour took the seat office i got
the seat back two and a half years later
having worked tirelessly for two years
campaigning and it just shows the
unpredictability that there is and uh
we've got two good very good candidates
who are working hard i hope that they're
going to be able to convince people in
those communities to vote for them and
vote conservative i'm backing them and
i'll be working to support them over the
coming days to do just that okay let's
talk rwanda and pretty patel of course
making it pretty clear she wants to push
ahead uh with the policy of sending
asylum seekers to
rwanda
after it was blocked in the courts when
do you hope the first plane to take off
well i can't comment on those
operational specifics of when that plane
might take off but we are talking about
a matter of weeks and we've been
consistently clear that we need to
deliver on this policy objective we
can't continue to have people making
perilous journeys across the channel
facilitated by evil criminal gangs
undercutting of course people coming via
safe and legal means let's come in there
and what are the safety legal means if
you're not from ukraine or afghanistan
where there are clear
routes to the uk
how do you claim asylum because if you
look at the government's advice um you
know that it says that you should apply
for asylum when you arrive in the uk but
it also says your claim effectively
won't be considered if you've traveled
to the uk through a safe third country i
mean it's basically impossible to claim
asylum legally isn't it well the point
is that what we do is we respond to
global crises as they emerge and we have
bespoke schemes that are in place to
provide the support that we want to give
and i think we have a proud tradition so
if you're not from if you're not from
ukraine and you're not from afghanistan
what is the safe and legal route for you
to claim asylum in the uk well there's
further examples look at for example the
response to the hong kong bno situation
look at the response to the syria crisis
where we accommodate that it's going to
be a deterrent for the people in france
currently when there isn't another route
for them to claim all of those people
sophia leaving what are fundamentally
safe countries to make perilous journeys
the idea that
one of the things we do for example is
we work with the unhcr in refugee camps
in areas around the world to provide
resettlement opportunities for people
obviously the unhcr do have a lot of
experience in handling those cases in
identifying particular vulnerabilities
where we can make the biggest impact in
terms of our help i think that's the
right approach so that in response to
individual crises we make the best
possible schemes that are as generous as
possible we've seen that in response to
ukraine in recent weeks and the
generosity of the british people but i
also think if we can help the most
vulnerable people on the face of the
planet that's precisely what we should
do
i just want to read the uk government's
current travel advice to rwanda
it says homosexual sexuality isn't
illegal in rwanda but it remains frowned
on by many lgbt individuals can
experience discrimination and abuse
including from local authorities there
are no specific anti-discrimination laws
that protect lgbt individuals are you
comfortable at sending people to a
country where
according to your own advice they can
experience discrimination and abuse
including from local authorities well
actually there's a fundamental principle
that cuts through the
rwandan constitution that deals with
anti-discrimination and you mentioned
the travel advice from the fcdo but
we've also had conducted a comprehensive
country report on rwanda that deals with
all of these matters that work is
carried out by a reputable team that
actually the courts have regularly
commended the quality of the work that
is done as being authoritative in terms
of those country by country reports and
it's also just worth pointing out that
the unhcr placed people in rwanda for
the purposes of providing sanctuary
which i think gives quite a strong
indication about how they feel about
people being safe in fact there's
representatives of the unhcr who are on
the record saying rwanda is a safe
environment for refugees but of course
in the end the fundamental principle
that we work through in this policy is
that people will only be relocated if it
is safe and appropriate for them it's
right that we take case by case
decisions taking proper account of
people's circumstances uh just finally
there's been some frustration from some
of your colleagues about the ruling by
the european court of human rights do
you think it's time to look at um
pulling out
so the prime minister said that we will
rule nothing out and that we're going to
have to look at this because we've got
to deliver on this policy we've made a
commitment we're determined to deliver
on this and i would argue that there's
lives at stake if we don't follow
through so it's something
you're leaving the door open but the
difficulty we've got at the moment is
obviously the european court of human
rights has handed down a ruling but we
haven't been even provided with the
detail of that ruling and the
underpinning rationale behind it
so when i left the office earlier all
it's saying my understanding is that you
should just wait until the the actual
judgment which is in july i don't think
it's unreasonable for us as ministers to
want to see
all of that information properly
presented and in full so that we can
make judgments about what is appropriate
in terms of next steps but the prime
minister said that we don't rule out
having to change our domestic law for
example if that's what's necessary in
order to facilitate this the thing is if
we don't we'll just continue to have
these criminal gangs exploiting people
taking their money all the risk to life
we've lost 27 lives in the channel in
november 39 people in the back of a
lorry in graze in essex a few years ago
that is what keeps me awake at night
frankly as the illegal migration
minister we've got to get to grips with
it failure is simply not an option okay
thank you very much for being on the
program uh tom perez love uh they're uh
talking about the rwanda policy but also
of course that resignation by uh lord
guy not much light shed on the reasons
behind that resignation let's see if we
can get a bit more detail now with our
deputy political editor
sam coates
what do you make of it do we have any
guidance on what happened and why well
it was interesting hearing minister tom
purseglove say that really it's for lord
guy to set out his reasons
that's true up to a point lord copper
because of course number 10 do know
exactly why lord geit says he resigned
because lord gait has written them a
letter and at some point boris johnson
may respond in writing but at the moment
i understand that there are no plans by
number 10 to release the letter from
lord guy which sets out the reasoning
for public consumption instead
lord guys issued a rather convoluted
couple of sentences statement uh
basically saying that he agreed with his
own decision to resign now what does
that
mean
isn't it i have to say sometimes i'm
picking uh
the the crux of his arguments it takes a
bit of time doesn't it you're incredibly
polite sophie it
it doesn't make much sense he's more
than elliptical quite a lot of time but
but what i would say about making a
statement like that and leaving it there
and not setting out on the record on his
own website what he thinks is this isn't
exactly the start of a sort of coup
attempt this wasn't if he doesn't set
out the reasons in public he doesn't
make clear his complaints about boris
johnson's behavior that he's leaving it
for us to infer but he's also not giving
perhaps those opponents to boris johnson
uh very much to go with a stick to sort
of beat the prime minister with or after
boris johnson has won that vote of no
confidence yes 140 at 48 mps voted
against him his position remains
uncertain but tonight would really
matter if lord guide had issued a
stinging statement setting out the
ethical failures playing into the hands
of the rebels instead an elliptical
statement issued at half past six
allowing us only to guess what's behind
this uh doesn't feel like it's the thing
that's about to trigger something big
interesting stuff and as you say
even though it feels like we can suppose
we can make some good assumptions about
why he resigned we don't have his words
and so it is a speculation uh really a
minute and sam thank you very much for
your analysis we'll have more from sam
later in the program well let's get the
reaction now from the uh labour party we
can speak to the shadow scottish
secretary in murray thank you very much
for being here
uh with us well let's talk about this
resignation what is your reaction
oh well we're not shocked because this
is the second ethics advisor that this
prime minister's have don't forget that
sir
alexander allen who was the previous
ethics advisor resigned two years ago
because he wrote a report into the
current home secretary bullying staff
and the prime minister backed pretty
patel and therefore he resigned so lord
guy came into the role from then um and
although his statement tonight doesn't
really say very much he has in the last
few weeks said that the prime minister's
ridiculed uh the ethical code the
ministerial code he said that he's been
skirting around the edges of the
ministerial code and i think his ethics
advisor had just had enough and it's a
ridicule of the ministerial code where
he said that that was a few weeks ago
when he had produced the report in terms
of the prime minister's
attitude to the ministerial code when he
said that he should have been explaining
all the way through part again
he said that he should uh explain why he
didn't believe he wrote the ministry and
he used the word ridicule the
ministerial code so it's little wonder
that lord guy has had to resign because
it's quite clear that the prime minister
has broken the ministerial court he will
now go to the privileges committee um
and you know the history is there for
people to see that what he's been saying
in parliament and what's been happening
in downing street and you know the prime
minister will now no longer get an
ethical adviser i mean who would want to
do that job it would be trying to find
similar to trying and hannibal lecter a
dentist i would imagine in terms of what
the job would entail now for someone who
wants to try and keep this prime
minister ethical i mean it's difficult
though isn't it because we we don't know
why he resigned yes we can obviously
make the the suppositions we know of
course he is in front of the
parliamentary committee uh we know of
course that he has expressed frustration
about how the prime minister dealt with
partygate
but it's not a smoking gun unless he
tells us why he resigned does it
well and he may tell us why he's
resigned but the word ethics and this
prime minister don't really go very
comfortably together and if you're the
prime minister's ethics advisor and
trying to advise on him sticking to the
ministerial code he's been fined by the
police he's been shown to at least have
lied in parliament whether that be
intentional or not and the privileges
committee will look at that so the job
that he's been asked to do is almost an
impossible job and he's decided
obviously to leave his role and i hope
in the next few days he does
what public service should do and what's
in the public interest and tells us
exactly why he's resigned and the the
details of the information that the
prime minister has got in terms of
history do you think as a public servant
he should explain the the reasons i
think it's in the public interest to do
so this is the second ethics advisor to
resign with this prime minister because
the prime minister hasn't been listening
to the advice that they had employed it
to give him he's already said a few
weeks ago that he thinks that the prime
minister should have been explaining why
he was sticking to the ministerial code
or not in terms of partygate and he
hasn't done that he's used the word
ridiculing the ministerial uh code and
today's decided to resign and i think
the public will look on this and realize
that the prime minister has now lost two
ethics advisors in the last two years
and that really is quite unacceptable in
the current environment okay um we've
been talking a bit about rwanda uh today
i keen to get your opinion on that would
a labour government cancel the agreement
with rwanda and stop sending asylum
seekers there well of course because we
wouldn't have it in the first place you
know it's quite clear that this is
unworkable it's unethical it's costly
and it's indeed illegal so would you
cancel it then we would yes i mean
that's but it's pretty clear i think
yvette cooper the shadow home secretary
was clear about that in the chamber
today she completely tore this policy
apart and let's be quite clear about
what this policy is doing it's taking
asylum seekers who are crossing the
channel dangerously in dinghies sticking
them on planes to rwanda and if their
asylum
application is successful under the
rules of the uk's asylum processes they
stay in rwanda that's unethical and it's
unworkable and it's hugely expensive and
it's interesting that i don't know if
tom said that in his interview with you
a few minutes ago but i don't know if he
told you how much this was going to cost
because the home sector refuses to tell
us so it's quite clear that this is a
policy that's just about extending the
culture what it does nothing to stop
people crossing so what is your strategy
then
because this is what the government says
it says look we had 440 uh people trying
to make that crossing yesterday it's
incredibly dangerous there's got to be
something to stop it what's your
strategy well what the government
government are trying to do what's your
structure so this is what i'm going to
tell what the government are trying to
do is to take the people off those boats
and send them to rwanda what they really
need to be trying doing is have a
relationship with the french and the
belgians to be able to try and stop
these questions from happening go after
the criminal gangs
you've got to go after the criminal
gangs it's not two years
not taking people out of dinghies and
sending them to rwanda now you said
there was 444 yesterday that's with the
rwanda policy so it's quite clearly not
going to work and it's unethical and
it's completely utterly unworkable and
of course it's now deemed to be illegal
as well so we need those um criminal
guides taken out now it's really strange
the
home secretary spent all of our time
creating a relationship with a country
like rwanda and none of our time talking
to the french or indeed the belgians in
terms of this issue we need to go after
those criminal gangs to stop those boats
coming across and maybe we need another
dublin arrangement which we need to work
on so that asylum seekers can be dealt
with in the country they first arrive in
okay let's just finally i want to talk
to you a little bit uh with your uh
scotland hat on because a nicholas
sturgeon yesterday was vowing to push
ahead with the idea of a second
independence uh referendum
now if you look at the current polling
local elections the current polling
everything is pointing towards hung
parliament uh in westminster uh it would
be a lot easier for labour of course to
form a government in that case uh rather
than conservatives
would you be prepared to do a deal with
the smp no no there'll be no deals into
the election there'll be no deals coming
out of the election and our challenge to
the snp if labour foreign administration
is the largest party would be do what
you did in 1979 if you wish to bring in
another conservative government or back
the labour administration that would be
well that is
isn't it saying that you'd back the
labour administration well they would
have to decide vote by vote if they
wanted to either vote with us or vote
with the conservatives that's not a
supply arrangement there's no
arrangement whatsoever as care has been
clear time and time again and that
sauber has been clear and will continue
to be clear no deal is going into the
election none coming out because we
don't require even if it lets the
conservatives into power it will let the
conservatives into power up with the
largest party because the s if you would
have to decide s p would have to decide
to vote with the conservatives to bring
it down a labour government i'm not sure
they would do that i don't think it's
under political interest to do that and
if they like us
share the view that we want to get rid
of this conservative government then the
people of scotland when they're voting
the next general election can do that by
voting labour okay iamara thank you very
much for being on the program this
evening busy start to the take we are
live here in westminster up next we're
going to be talking to our panel about
the resignation of lord guyt trying to
find out what they made of today's prime
minister's questions
[Music]
hello welcome back to the take now the
political highlight of midweek well at
least for political geeks like me is
prime minister's questions when the
prime minister faces party leaders and
backbenchers from all sides now this
week after being told to put a bit more
welly in from his deputy angela raynor
sakirstama compared boris johnson to a
contestant on love island who was giving
the public the ick here's what our
political correspondent ali forskey made
of it all this is pmq's unwrapped it was
a particularly rowdy prime minister's
questions last week keir starman was
accused of being lackluster heavy on the
detail lacking in punch this week he
focused on the economy with some
colorful metaphors
the force just isn't with him anymore
[Applause]
he thinks he's obi-wan kenobi
the truth is he's jabber the heart
he thinks he's on love island
trouble is prime minister i'm reliably
informed that contestants that give the
public the ick get booted out
when did screwing business turn from a
flippant comment into economic policy
and his questions were much shorter and
snappier than last week britain is set
for lower growth
than every major economy
except russia
why
the labour leader decided to push on the
economy our analysis of his language
shows he focused on words like inflation
growth business the prime minister
wanted to talk about jobs using words
like investment and employment one thing
boris johnson definitely wanted to talk
about was labour's position on rail
strikes what would be useful in
supporting the uk economy right now
would be if the leader of the labour
party ended his sphinx-like silence
about the rmt's
coming up in the course of the next
couple of weeks
will he will he now uh will he now break
with his shadow transport secretary and
denounce labour's rail strikes
the pm even prompting a telling off from
the speaker by turning the questions on
to the labour leader just to remind the
prime minister he seems to have gone his
prime minister's question he's got
opposition
[Applause]
i don't want the strikes to go ahead but
he does elsewhere the lib dem leader ed
davey was keen to talk about fuel prices
in places like devon a week before a
by-election in devon
the rural fuel duty relief scheme is
supposed to help
by taking money off the price of petrol
but some rural counties aren't eligible
like cumbria
like shropshire
and like devon
a coincidence not lost on the tory
benches
but pmq's was just as interesting for
what kierstalmer didn't ask the prime
minister there were no questions on the
big divisive issues of the day by the
northern ireland protocol and the
government's rwanda plan thorny issues
around brexit and immigration labour
wanted to avoid
they go getting the ick who would have
thought that would be a a word that
you'd be hearing in the house of commons
today i'm not sure what's on my uh pmq's
bingo card anyway well that was the
commons uh this afternoon let's have a
little chat now uh to what people
watching on sky news made of all the
politics uh today we're joined now by
uh viewers panel uh hello everybody um
this is something we do every week we
try and balance it politically
geographically just to try and take the
temperature from our own viewers about
some of the hot political issues of the
day now i thought it was going to be
rwanda but i really do want to talk to
you about the resignation that we've
seen this evening again of course lord
geit let's talk to you rob tyler first
at shall we now uh rob tyler he's a
familiar face if you've been watching
the take in recent weeks conservative
voter uh rob talk to me about lord geit
are you bothered do you think it's a bad
luck for the prime minister do you think
we should all move on what is your take
well i think um lord gait has been
a value member of the government team
and i'm sure that his advice and his
intelligence been missed
but i think like any adviser if if your
advice isn't being taken then eventually
you're going to take your ball and go
home
uh there you go rob a view on that rob
just quickly on rwanda i'm interested to
get your view
on that as a conservative voter as well
uh because we've heard a lot you know if
you know people particularly on the left
i guess uh who are really unhappy with
this policy i think it's inhumane
are you someone who is supportive of it
i think it's difficult to to come out as
a supporter with a knee-jerk reaction
from others uh thinking that you may be
a racist
or some such but i do feel that
it has been important to take back um
our own borders and we have to do
something we can't allow undocumented
people unchecked into the country and
for their sakes we need to uh to ensure
that they're safe coming over and that
when they do get here that they realize
that the the pavements aren't uh the
streets aren't paired with gold it's not
dick whittington and that they could
come unstuck and end up in a very very
bad situation we need their own safety
as well to be thought about um moving
people to rwanda
could be um a little bit
a bit far but but if you took them back
to france they'll be back over next week
so there has to be that's this somewhere
spotlight
okay uh interesting stuff thank you for
sharing your view uh with us uh this
evening uh rob let's bring in roz now uh
shall we ross uh you're definitely
someone who's had some strong views on
boris johnson in recent weeks uh labour
voter uh from york um what did you make
of uh the lord guys resignation
well i think he's very sensibly realized
that um he's unable to do the job
and he's just been given the run around
um by boris johnson
people who are associated with boris
johnson are getting themselves in in a
bad bad situation he can't do the job
boris johnson is a serial liar is
behaving unethically the last thing i'd
want on my cv is having been his ethics
advisor and i think that's you know that
that has dawned on lord gait and that
seems to be very clearly what's going on
he's divorcing himself from it because
he's unable to do the job uh royals very
quickly what did you make of kierstar at
pmq's dad jokes or was it really funny
what did you think
i wanted two of them landed i mean i
thought the idea of boris johnson trying
jedi mind tricks just repeating the same
things often enough and hoping people
are going to believe it i mean i think
that that smacked of of the truth i
think his trauma's got a really
difficult job actually because
how do you
continually ask questions of somebody
who doesn't answer them and who blusters
and lies
so you've got a grown up asking
questions of somebody who is behaving
well it's more like a cartoon character
these days isn't it he's becoming almost
a caricature of himself
um
it's desperately sad to see our country
has come to this that that this person
is the prime minister it's
it's quite unbelievable and it really
does look like we have a grown-up
asking questions of a well it's like a
toddler having a tantrum the man's
deluded oh there you go strong
views as always from you uh royals we
can always rely on you uh to uh
make your views about boris johnson very
well known uh let's talk to er pradeep
now uh pradeep sekka theron who is a
labour voter um i'm really interested to
talk to you a little bit about the
rwanda uh policies i know that you were
speaking to my producer a little bit
earlier um saying that you have a family
story you're a war refugee
yourself that you came to the uk when
you were six from sri lanka so i'm just
interested in your perspective
on on this policy
yeah um quite frankly i'm lucky that my
parents took the risk to come to this
country a country i love and i've lived
the british dream i truly have
having said that it doesn't mean that
i'm for allowing everyone into the
country
i think this policy is ill-thought-off
and poor in execution
i do believe there's more we should be
doing in early routes in terms of
looking at investments and how we
actually nip the bud uh can we go back
to the countries where these individuals
originating from i'm giving them more
legal options to apply to come to this
country
are we looking far beyond france and
belgium and working with international
partners to stop criminal gangs because
sophie to be frank somewhere in the
world now a family's taking a risk to
come to this country because of the
british dream and they will not stop a
because they probably don't know about
the rwanda death run
b
they frankly don't care so they will
always take the risk and even if you
stop certain business models and certain
criminals there'll be more criminals to
take their place so we need
very
thought out investments in countries
where these uh people are originating
from and stopping the criminal networks
in other countries such as north africa
turkey and other routes and not just
closer to home really interesting to get
your uh perspective another person's
perspective that i'm keen to get on
rwanda is stella stella finley you're a
green voter maybe a libdem voter not a
conservative supporter but i'm
interested in your perspective on rwanda
because you say that you know people
who've lived in rwanda what's your take
on this policy
yes i i knew a couple of people who'd
worked in rwanda for a number of years
and
they loved the country
and
this was before the hutu uprising
but the tutsis are now in power again
and i think that rwanda has been
misrepresented because it's a beautiful
country people actually go there on
holiday so i don't think it's such a
dreadful destination for these people
um they are going to be well looked
after
it's reputed to be one of the safest
countries in africa
so i don't think they are at risk and i
don't i think they will be looked after
because
i think that money is obviously
following these people to rwanda and so
um the government there wants the money
and they just wouldn't allow anything to
go wrong with it
interesting stuff it does feel like
we're getting a bit of splits of opinion
i can see some shaking heads in the
answer as well just quickly can we do a
bit of a show of hands if you're in
favor of the rwanda policy and i know
it's a bit more complicated than that
but if you're in favor of the real
wonder policy generally can you put your
hand up
overall
and if you're not in favor put your hand
up now
so yeah majority more
against the policy than four but there
is a bit of a difference of opinion so
yeah really interesting to talk to
everyone about that and i know it is
quite sensitive talking about these
issues so we do appreciate it uh right
let's go back to little guy shall we uh
belinda campbell um you're a swing voter
so i know always swing voters are always
quite fascinating to see how how these
issues land
are you troubled by the resignation of
lord guyt
i think it's an opportunity for somebody
to make a statement
at that time
um you know it's kind of unspoken well
it's not unspoken but it because he
hasn't gone into details it is making a
statement
and to say that it's the right thing to
do
could be so many reasons
so
it does carry weight until we
have more information
and um
yeah i think it's i'm looking forward to
hearing what what the real reason was or
there's only more than one reason has
partygate changed your opinion of the
prime minister
yes i think if you are responsible for a
country running a country and you're
held in that position you should behave
in a way that's um respectable
and um you know
have a make a good example of yourself
so it doesn't
give it doesn't make a good example if
you're breaking laws and speaking on
television telling everybody to do one
thing and then doing another
okay and then just finally let's end
with chloe shall we chloe forest
conservative voter you live in there
cumbria chloe don't you
um lord guys uh partygate um how
much weight do you do you place on the
fact that lord guy has felt that his
position is untenable or do you think
it's time that we moved on
um i think
firstly i think it's really really
concerning to be honest that he's had
two ethics advisors that have have now
resigned while he's been in power i
think
um as ross said just before
i think is it something you would want
you know to be named as
during this period when he's been
breaking rules you know on your cv so i
think
he probably has done the right thing i
probably would have done the same and
i've sat here week in week out and i'd
have fought borrows his corner quite a
bit
however sometimes it's made quite
difficult
i'm interested to hear you say that
chloe because you're right you have been
on a lot of shows and often in the
minority
you've said look let's cut boris johnson
a bit of slack even though you're you
know a nurse you kind of work throughout
the pandemic so you do know more than
most of us about you know the rules and
the impact of that
are you reaching the end of your tether
a little bit with it is that right is
that or am i going too far
yeah no i think there is there is quite
a few things i think i think i do see
the good in the things that he's doing i
think he's had a really tough run as
well i think you know he started off he
came into power he had to deal with
brexit he had to deal with the pandemic
he's got the one ukraine you know so
many things have been kind of thrown at
him however he has made mistakes
i think some of them we should kind of
move on from
but it's getting to the point almost now
how many how many mistakes can he make
before people do lose patience a little
bit with that because
um as much as i do think he's done good
i think
yeah it's it's just hard to defend him a
little bit now and certain things that
he comes out with like i've just seen
something earlier that i got sent and i
i just think it's not he's not
prioritizing very well he's not you know
putting things in the order that you
should be putting is he's concentrating
on things that are sometimes unimportant
you know we've got people that can't
afford to feed the kids that go to work
every day and he wants to carry on you
know
flights from blackpool airport but
that's no good when people can't afford
to feed the kids they can't afford to go
on flights from blackpool airport it's
just managing those priorities isn't it
and he's not seeming to do that very
well
really interesting uh we are out of time
uh thank you very much for a wide range
of views i did pepper you with topics of
it so i appreciate everyone being up for
uh giving us your view on a variety say
much appreciated
you're watching the take we are live in
westminster up next we'll hear a
question of the week where we give the
backbencher a chance to respond to the
prime minister
[Music]
hello welcome back now it's our regular
chance to speak to a backbencher as we
pick our pmq of the week it's the one
that really caught our eye during the
session earlier and today it's on a
really important talking break it is
this one
mental health support is vital for
victims of sexual crimes when a
rotherham survivor who's here today
reported her childhood abuse to the
police they told her not to go for
counselling as it could be used against
her in court
your attorney general is challenging the
rules so it's even easier for defense
teams to access victims counselling
notes having an immediate chilling
effect
survivors shouldn't be forced to choose
between their mental health and justice
prime minister please stop this yes
sarah champion there the mp for
rotherham now of course usually the
questioner doesn't get a chance to
respond to the prime minister's answer
to that question the idea of this is
we're trying to put that right and each
week let an mp do that so let's talk now
to sarah champion labour and people
rotherham she joins us now
what did you make of the prime
minister's response to your question
um
well the best i can say is it was
respectful uh so i appreciate that not
least because the constituent that i've
been campaigning with this on for the
last 18 months was was physically there
in the chamber so that was a blessing
unfortunately the answer that he gave
was that you know he was all over this
and of course he was putting victims
first but the reality is that
prosecutions for rape crimes um my
constituent was a child abuse crime are
down to an all-time low they've actually
plummeted from 1.6 of those being
prosecuted well the crimes being
reported to them being prosecuted and
then going to jail
and is even lower now it's now dropped
to 1.3
which is ridiculous um and what i've
been
asking for relentlessly is for victims
and survivors just to have a bit of
support so my constituent was told by
the police that she couldn't get
counseling support it would be used
against her so for 18 months of going
through a really harrowing trial she had
to do that on her own her family had
stepped away from her largely at that
point and she had she had no counselling
um it left her deeply traumatized to the
extent that she actually left the
country and has only recently come back
interesting i was oh i was really keen
to be honest to
talk to you this evening because you
know your question struck a bit of a
nerve with me because i did an interview
with a rape survivor
uh about a year ago it would have been
and she talked a lot about the process
that she went through her phone being
confiscated by police she received the
same advice that any therapy that she
received could be accessed uh by the
trial uh and effectively used against to
those notes and it really left a bit of
an impression on me and it was i was i
guess i was quite shocked to be honest
what some people have to go through
to get justice how do you think we treat
victims of sexual crime in this country
um
i mean
i know too much about this and i have
spoken to
victims and survivors from all over the
country this isn't isolated
i i liken it to if my car was stolen and
i went into the police station reported
it then they would automatically believe
me until the evidence was pointed you
know that i was making up
if you report a sexual crime in this
country whether it's it's rape whether
it's sexual violence domestic abuse
child abuse the immediate assumption is
that you the victim are in some way
lying or complicit which i find is just
an extraordinary position to be in
and the prime minister
didn't address the substantive part of
my um point which was on the 26th of
july the attorney general is going to
loosen the restrictions that are already
in place around counseling notes being
given to basically your perpetrators
lawyers
so that
there aren't any restrictions it almost
becomes an automatic the bar will be so
low and the reason why
that's having such a dramatic effect
is the person that raped you
is going to know not just about the
the trauma that they've put you through
but they're going to know all of your
past history as well that's going to be
into the public domain that's going to
be used your deepest fears are going to
be used against you in a court
add on to that you know apart from the
the horror and the fact that survivors
now just don't want to report as it is
and it's going to only get worse add on
to that that the reason part of the
reason that we're getting such low
prosecutions is the massive court
backlog
so think that now
the cps and prosecutors are going to
have to go through even more information
most of it won't be relevant because
that filter that currently in place will
be gone and and you just think how are
you ever going to get justice for sexual
crimes in this country i don't
understand what this new rule change is
about
and as you say you know not just you
know the the person you're bringing
into the court knowing about your sort
of deepest thoughts but also you know
your loved ones as well whether that's
your children or your mum i'm sure that
a lot of people will be you know not
necessarily want all these things to be
public
um you mentioned that about the court
backlog which is a really important part
of the story uh we haven't got long left
but how concerned are you about the
impact of that do you think it could
could mean people wait longer for
justice
um well it will mean that people won't
get justice uh it's already at breaking
point and you're looking at you know an
average of two years now um and what
that means is people's lives are in
limbo you're literally waiting for that
phone call for two years of your life
and to be quite honest i can understand
why a lot of victims uh just walk away
at that point because they just want to
shut the door on it it's an open wound
and they're having to wait two years
before they get any sort of retribution
for it and to be quite honest
particularly in rape cases the
prosecution rates are so low
why would you want to go through that
and i speak to too many survivors that
say the court process which is by nature
adversarial was as bad as the the abuse
so
i i just think we're going to lose
justice over this
we're out of time thank you so much for
coming on a really powerful interview
there thank you
wow important interview there but lots
of takes uh this evening and we could
have our usual post-match roundup with
our deputy political editor at sam coats
who's uh here
again
we've been talking a lot about little
guys and i guess i'm just interested to
get your perspective on it and we were
saying earlier that we don't know why he
resigned but
right now
how secure is boris johnson in his
premiership do you think well i mean
that's the question everybody's asking i
don't think in of itself lord geit's
elliptical resignation he has resigned
as he conducted the job quite frankly is
the trigger that will cause
sort of significant action amongst tory
mps it's harder for them to take action
anyway after boris johnson won that vote
last week and gave himself a year's
protection from a uh another further
voice of no confidence but my gosh
sophie things are zig-zagging all over
the place uh if you just look at that
interview that you did with the minister
from the home office tom purse club he
said we have to keep on the table the
option of withdrawing from the european
convention of human rights now why is
that significant
because
at
7 30 this morning uh one cabinet
minister and then at 11 a.m a little bit
later this morning another cabinet
minister both said that wasn't on the
table and then at lunchtime danny street
said it was and the entire government
position switched around
what does this tell you it tells you
that this is a government zigzagging
around why is it zigzagging around
because it's uncertain what it needs to
do in order to maintain confidence in
the problem and i guess what you've got
with the zigzagging is different
factions in the party effectively
wrestling for control
that's right and at the moment the signs
since that vase of no confidence last
week are that when under pressure boris
johnson will lean into the arguments
from those on the right of his party now
whether he can deliver what they demand
is another question that'll take 15
months to a year for many of those
things but that's his instinct at the
moment i think we did hear from that
from tom perez glover did see him this
evening as well sam thanks very much for
your uh roundup always uh interesting uh
to talk to you at sam coats there
another
busy
midweek point in westminster
i have to say when we launched this
program on wednesday nights we thought
that it was always going to be busy on
these evenings and it certainly has
proved to be the case we had a shock
resignation this evening that of course
is off the back of another busy day in
westminster with uh as you said sam was
saying
wrestling for control going from all
sides we'll be back next week and every
week wednesdays at 9 00 pm but next up
you've got sky news at 10 thanks for
watching
[Music]
you